hey everyone how's it going my name is
miyuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about tech career and life
so i think that finding a good manager
is one of the most
important factors in deciding on a job
because i strongly believe that a
manager is there to help you be the best
person that you can be
for your work they're there to coach you
through challenging situations
provide new opportunities and just
generally be
invested in your growth and i feel i've
been really lucky because my most recent
manager jordana kwok embodies all of
this
she's an engineering leader at netflix
and recently i had her come on to
mooco's corner
my show about leading a life that feels
more you in both your life and tech
career
i honestly think that she's like one of
the best managers out there
not only was she a role model for me and
that she's also an asian american woman
and not only did we share
interests like ios development and the
whole women in tech movement
but she really enabled me to explore my
career interests and try out different
things
our one-on-ones consisted of
conversations about anything from
deep discussions about tech culture to
deep dives into app architecture to the
best boba in the bay area
to sometimes her just giving me space to
cry about something that i was really
frustrated about at work
i think that she's a manager who truly
cares for her people
not just in their work but as whole
human beings
being able to work with her was
absolutely my favorite part about
working at netflix
and the lessons she taught me through
her coaching and the work we did
together
are ones that'll bring with me into like
everything that i do
so today i wanted to share parts of the
conversation we had together
we talked about the work that we did
together you'll kind of get to see the
dynamic that we had
she shares how she's been supporting her
team through kovid especially with their
mental health
and we'll also talk about women in tech
because it is women's history month
after all
hopefully by the end you'll have learned
a thing or two or at least been able to
see how important it is to have a really
good manager by your side in your career
and also you'll just see like how
amazing jordana was and why she was like
my favorite part about working at
netflix
this is probably going to be a long
video so i'll leave everything broken up
into chapters
and i hope you enjoy first i always like
to start with like a good origin story
so like maybe let's talk about like
how we met because i think that's kind
of a unique thing i think there's
lessons learned in that as well
but i i believe i met you because you
invited me to
an event that was hosted at netflix for
ui engineering is that right
yeah it was about the customer journey
into the netflix experience and we had
a whole panelist of women who worked
from
end to end uh throughout that experience
who shared
their work you know there there were a
lot of
women that we wanted to you know have on
stage
kind of speak to this the the technical
uh complexities
of all the problems that they were able
to solve and to kind of
really showcase uh to other women that
hey
there there's a place for us you know at
the table
you know in the product and in you know
the services that we build
so yeah i always like to think about
that because i think it's you know in
tech it's really important to broaden
your network and to connect with
people and make relationships like that
um and so i think
kind of this is one example in which i
hold close to my heart
going to events like that can turn into
wonderful relationships such as these
and now we're here
on my show which is kind of a surreal
thing to think about again i wanted to
highlight women's history month because
this whole month is around
celebrating women i love this month i
get to hear about all the amazing women
in stem and other fields doing
incredible work i really wanted you to
have to be on my show in march because
eugene is slash has been one of my
biggest role models for being a woman in
tech
unfortunately like women in tech kind of
as you get
more senior in your career i feel like
are very few and far between
like the fact that i was able to meet
you and get to know you and work with
you
i think has been really a true highlight
uh in my career
yeah definitely i loved having you on
the team
especially hearing about your
experiences because that's
everyone comes with a different
experience um you know how they got into
tech
or even you know how they got into just
even coding to begin with right you
might not even
have a job right now but you know you
might be dabbling in coding and you
might come from a very different
background like maybe
maybe you studied arts right and
learning about everyone's different
perspectives and how they got to where
they are today
and how they want to kind of move
forward and kind of bring that passion
to
you know the workplace that's something
that you know i'm super passionate about
one of the things that i told you early
on when we were talking about
diversity equity and inclusion and this
was a personal frustration of mine
is that diversity is something that uh
is a really hard problem to crack
everybody is trying to crack it at
different parts of the pipeline whether
that be
high school stem education to
college-level computer science to
whatever or
maybe even earlier right like teaching
toddlers how to code or something but
it's not something that like software
engineers or ics feel necessarily super
we we don't really feel like we can
impact that
that much a lot of folks are empowered
to do volunteering which definitely
helps
but at the end of the day it's a really
really big problem um and so when it
comes to hiring on a team and finding
folks from underrepresented backgrounds
yeah it's a it's just really hard and i
feel like sometimes you just like hit a
wall where you're just like there's just
not that many women or minorities in
tech and also i kind of i think
diversity efforts tend to be spearheaded
by
people teams hr teams recruiting teams
leadership
but at the end of the day it's like
engineers like individual contributors
ics
are a big part of this because we are
the world in which
all these people come into um and be a
part of i remember talking about like
what can we do like what can ics do
i think sometimes there is even like a
like a
sentiment that like diversity and
inclusion doesn't impact me
because like i don't influence hiring or
something like that
but in fact it influences things so much
and so we kind of really tapped into the
kind of inclusion
part of stuff i kind of want to hit us
off to jordana because she really helped
lead a lot of this to happen too but
maybe do you want to talk about
like what you think about all of that
and then the talk about the ind series
that we came up with
yeah it was awesome i still distinctly
remember
that particular conversation we had
where you're like do you think we could
do something about this
and i was like um okay maybe we could do
something grassroots because
a lot of companies these efforts are
like top down very top down like
you know someone maybe from hr says we
need to do this
and then all the teams go ahead and you
know maybe it's like implicit bias
training but
there's not a lot of places where i've
seen like a grassroots effort
to really move the needle in terms of uh
diversity and inclusion you know with
like you said you know you can only do
so much to
invite people to the party meeting the
diversity side of things but after
you've invited them to the party if they
decide
hey this doesn't feel great i'm gonna
leave then you know all of that effort's
gone down the drain so you know the one
thing that we can
have a lot of impact on especially you
know as team members from a grassroots
perspective
is you know how do we how do we keep
people
at these workplaces um and make them
feel like they belong so that once
they're in the door and they're invited
to the party they can they can be
themselves right
and so we focused on like you said the
inclusion part of things and you know
how do we then
get team members to to create this
inclusive environment
i loved your first kind of idea around
that because it wasn't like jumping
directly to these hard topics of how do
we attract women it's more
around actually how do we relate to one
another and
and building that trust and uh
vulnerability so
i think the first workshop that you had
pitched was around
you know how did we get into tech it's
something that you would want to do
regardless i think
of whether or not you're you're tackling
this issue directly and we were just
experimenting too right i think that it
was like
an awesome collaboration because neither
of us were would know like hey how
how would people react to this or
whether it would be successful
but the feedback that we got afterwards
like everyone wanted more
everyone was like oh my gosh i learned
so much about you know my team members
uh when we connected like a week or two
ago to kind of talk about
um like having you on the show actually
i was pleased to hear that like you've
kind of they're still going on um
especially
so because of the pandemic and how it's
affected kind of mental health because
mental health i think is another axis
um around diversity and inclusion and
it's some it's a topic that's getting
a lot more attention now because of the
pandemic but even before so
i guess i'm i wanted to hear a little
bit about kind of
what you and the team have been doing to
support each other through the pandemic
in each other's mental health
yeah i mean uh kudos to you know all of
the efforts that
um you kick started like we continued
this
and continued a lot of the format we did
shrink it down to
an hour from 90 minutes just because
virtually it's a little
trickier to block off so much time and
we were trying to be really cognizant of
people's time because some people
are perhaps you know responsible for
child child care or elder care
so that those have been challenges that
we've encountered so far
because it's not really working remote
it's working
you know working in a crisis while being
remote
which is very different we're all just
trying to like get by
and it is certainly not what we would
expect
even if we were fully you know
distributed where services like child
care
you know schools are available so we we
certainly
kind of started to recognize that people
were kind of at different points and
experiencing different things i in
particular noticed that some people were
trying to
put all their time and effort into work
because
that's their outlet right they just had
nothing else they wanted to kind of keep
their minds off of
what was going on outside and that other
people were barely kind of hanging on
and struggling but when you know
engineers see other engineers
be really productive they're like oh my
gosh i gotta i gotta match my
co-worker otherwise i might be seen as
you know not being productive
in this environment that's not really
healthy and something
that as much as you know me as a manager
saying you can you know go at your own
pace
take your own time you know take time
off i think there's this peer pressure
that
we all feel right that we need to show
up and be
you know put on this space that we're
we're still being productive it was like
you know difficult to crack without
having everyone kind of come
come together and then actually share
with one another
what they're really going through so we
did another like it's almost like
another vulnerability session where
we had everyone just share what they're
going through their personal lives like
are they
okay you know some people might be
living alone and they are feeling
such a huge sense of isolation that is
very different than someone who might be
like hey i
have two kids who are now you know going
through virtual learning and and
trying to keep them occupied during that
time and having people share those
experiences and recognize that okay
we're struggling in different ways
we're all struggling but just in
different ways it's okay if we don't
try to one-up each other in terms of
productivity
and and that has led a lot of people
then to kind of you know take care of
themselves like
in terms of like whether it's like
physical health mental health
and kind of uh back off a little bit
just
knowing so that pure like relieving that
peer pressure essentially
i mean that was just 60 minutes and i
you know i
i think those types of things can really
bring a team together and
also open the discussion to more
difficult
topics around mental health and that
that usually
is stigmatized in many work environments
it's like we don't talk about anxiety
or we don't talk about depression i
thought that was you know
maybe another way to kind of bring to
light that hey it's okay
to talk about these issues yeah
definitely i love that
you've kind of helped open up the
conversation
i mean even thinking about mental health
i just remembered when i had a really
particularly rough time with my mental
health
you were there for me the whole time and
i remember telling you and i was like i
don't really
feel like myself and i need some time
off and you were
the most understanding and so i think
everyone's really lucky to have you as a
manager number one
uh and i love that like you know it's an
hour of a week which
some ics are like i don't want to spend
an hour talking about my feelings but it
really can
uh have lasting effects i think between
relationships
within the workplace and because
engineering
tech in general is just such a
collaborative effort
uh it's completely worth it to talk
about that stuff and it is uncomfortable
but
um it's something that everybody i think
can ramp up to and hopefully
good things come out of it thank you so
much for watching the video i hope you
found it valuable
if you would like to watch the recording
of the full show that i did with jordana
then you can become a member today by
clicking the join button down below
and getting access to the live recording
for as little as 99 cents
also i should note that you becoming a
member helps support my channel there's
like no middle person
no ad or anything in between you and i
i really appreciate everybody who's
already become a member and
allows me to do what i do oh and also
the full audio recording will be
available
through the mucous corner podcast i also
wanted to take a moment to thank the
sponsor of today's video
brilliant one of the things that i found
about working at netflix is that it's a
company that really values people who
are
really good at learning how to think and
brilliant is an incredible platform to
help you do
just that brilliant is a problem-solving
based website and app with a hands-on
approach
with over 60 interactive courses in math
science and computer science
they all have an element of storytelling
code writing interactive challenges
and problem solving as part of their
courses you can use brilliant to get
into the habit of learning new things
every day
like maybe you can set aside some
saturday mornings to learn something new
like how neural networks actually work
or getting a better understanding of
machine learning
so make sure to check out brilliant
today by going to brilliant.org
hello myuco where the first 200 people
will get
20 off the annual premium subscription
thank you so much for watching make sure
to subscribe to this channel
and i will see you next time bye